so Madam Prime Minister it is
a pleasure for me to welcome you
here at the Berlaimont for this first
working meeting we are
together facing unprecedented challenges the
war in Ukraine and its consequences at
all levels I am very
grateful to the  France for her
unfailing support for Ukraine isos
sanction against Russia and it is with
admiration that I remember the role of
the French president in the
European response immediately after
the invasion
climate change is the second
major subject that we  will discuss it's
repercussions on our societies are
increasingly important we have a
very clear roadmap
it is now a matter of working
together to implement it in
France and in the European Union this
requires adaptations of our
energy systems and our
sectoral legislation, for example that adopted
yesterday in the European Parliament on
electric cars,
only one and three collaboration between
the European levels and the
national level can give the expected results
and finally we are facing a
hardening of the international economic context.
demands from us
new answers and
adapted answers this is the objective of our
industrial plan within the framework of the Green Pact
we have on this plan a large zone of
convergence and I know that France
shares the main axes of our
proposals
whether it is for example reducing the
regulatory complexity for
clean technologies or in terms of
financing whether it is State aid
or European funds to conclude
allow me to thank you for
the constant commitment on all these
subjects France is playing  a leading role
in our debates and I am delighted to
be able to discuss all these subjects with
you now in this hour of
work
thank you very much Madam President
dear
I am very happy to be here in
Brussels for the first time in the
context of my duties  of Prime
Minister to meet the President
of the European Commission, Ms.
Vanderleyen, whom I thank for her
invitation,
this meeting is extremely
important for me in a context where
the challenges that Europe must take up are
of course not lacking the first subject
which continues to structure
basically the European agenda is
Ukraine
in eight days it will be exactly one
year since the Russian war of aggression
against Ukraine was launched
in the face of this tragedy which concerns us
all Europe has shown its unity and
stands by the side of Ukraine
Europe's aid has been and will continue to
be massive on the humanitarian,
military, financial and even economic level
our determination to act is also
reflected in the adoption of 9 packages of
sanctions against Russia  and we are
currently working on
the adoption of a tenth package
the objective is simple to
suffocate the Russian economy and prevent it
from financing this unprovoked and unjustified war
I know, Madam President, your
commitment to ensuring that the
European response  be up to it I wanted to
tell you France's recognition
and reassure you, as the President of the
Republic had the opportunity to say, of
our full determination to continue to
support Ukraine
the other major question that concerns us
is  on the challenges facing
the European Union in terms of
energy
these questions have considerably
structured the European agenda in recent
months
if we have responded to the emergency and
although gas prices have fallen, it
remains essential to reform the
European market  electricity in order to
guarantee that
price volatility is better controlled tomorrow
the European Commission will make a
legislative proposal to this effect in
March
France fully supports this
initiative with a very simple objective to
ensure that prices
correspond to the  reality of production costs
let's be clear our consumers
could not understand that it would be
otherwise
more broadly as you said Madam
President we are talking about the
ecological and energy transition that Europe
must imperatively lead and succeed
we Europeans have  made
very ambitious commitments on
the goal of carbon neutrality by 2050
we all have our part to play we
must act in all areas and
in the wake of the Green Deal France
has launched ecological planning to
achieve this goal
we know that  one of the
main levers for success and industry
we must work together on a
European industrial policy
fully adapted to our ecological ambitions
allow me once again to pay
tribute to the action of the
European Commission which put on the table the
first  February very
ambitious and concrete proposals in the service of
this renewed industrial policy
they enabled
last week's European Council to lay down
essential milestones on the way forward
France is in support of the adopted
roadmap taking
action and all the more so  more important that
certain legislation raises
legitimate questions on the part of
our companies I am thinking in particular of
inflation reduction acts if we are
of course delighted with the ambition
displayed by the United States in terms of
climate this legislation can also
have consequences  industrial
negative effects on Europe
I would add that Europe must know how to
affirm its interests and promote its
values ​​on the international scene.
This is particularly true in
commercial matters, where we must at the
same time be firm in the face of
distorting and intransigent practices on the
respect for human,
environmental and social rights,
ladies and gentlemen, this list is
not exhaustive, of course, these are
some of the challenges that will
occupy us the most in the months to come, as you
know, Madam President, how much
France by  the voice of the President of the
Republic and deeply committed to the
service of a sovereign and united Europe
and you can therefore count on our
full support to carry out its
many many projects before the
end of the current term of office thank you thank you
very much